That is gold wire isn’t it? Ok. It is so
small you probably won’t
see it.
So gold is an element, one of the few elements
that I think
everybody is very familiar with. Women and
many men wear
it as a wedding ring. I don’t wear a wedding
ring because as a
chemist I am frightened that it will react
with mercury and go
silver and colour and therefore no longer
look nice.
So here we have a very, very fine sample of
Grade 1
research-quality gold. So everybody knows
that gold is used
to make rings and lots of jewellery and we
do that because it
is inert. It does not react with anything
at all.
Gold used to be, recently, used quite a lot
for filling
people’s teeth or false teeth because it
is chemically very un-
reactive. And gold, like silver, is an element
which is found
naturally, in rocks and so on, actually as
metallic gold. In fact
unlike a lot of the other elements it is largely
found as
metallic gold. This is why people pan for
gold and so on
because they fall - the heavy pieces fall
to the ground.
So you can very happily wear it for hundreds
of years and it
will not oxidise or tarnish.
Gold is very dense, so if this was made of
gold, I could not
just lift it up because it would be just too
heavy and the
mines that make platinum and the other noble
metals also
get quite a large amount of gold at the same
time because
gold occurs naturally with a greater abundance
than these
other metals.
Gold obviously is also a storage of wealth
because of the fact
that it is so inert, in terms of value, I
think this gold is
perhaps maybe about 10 pence. It is probably
more
expensive than that actually because this
is Grade 1.
Recently chemists have realised that gold
although it is
chemically rather un-reactive, can form quite
good catalysts
and so that there is a lot of research going
on at the moment
to try and see what gold can and cannot do.
Because as it is
much more abundant than other heavy metals
there is quite
enough gold to make all the catalysts we could
possibly want.
There is 1.17 grams when it is full. I think
there is probably
about 50mg. Ok, let’s pop that back in.
The alchemist idea of making gold from lead
and so on is
completely mad, it is not physically possible.
However in
modern times when people made/got nuclear
reactors and
even more when they got so called accelerators
where they
can use electric fields to make the nucleus
of atoms travel at
enormous speed then they can actually make
two atoms bang
together and turn into another one, but this
is on a very small
scale, atom by atom, and is it not a way that
you could
industrially manufacture. If you want to become
rich there are
better ways than trying to make gold.